vista outdoors reports ammunition
backlog over a billion dollars
we currently have a we currently have
over a year's
worth of orders for ammunition in excess
of one billion met said during a
november fifth call
with demand for outstripping supply and
inventory levels in the channel at our
all-time lows
uh at all-time lows we see strong demand
continuing and this metric
informs our viewpoint of what a recovery
normalization
could look like vista was reporting its
second quarter earnings when ceo chris
meltz
detailed what announced the backlog
which he called
unprecedented for the for the company an
estimated 1.9 million firearms were sold
october this year 1.9 million firearms
that's a 65
spike from the same month in 2019
according to data provided by small arm
analytics
and forecasting so you know is this a
good thing is this a bad thing and what
is it telling us about the current state
of things i think it's a spotlight on
what's going
on in this country you can't have a
conversation with someone right now
where they haven't said oh i'm gonna get
a gun
or i just got a gun oh i got my gun
ready do you know how often people say
that
doctors doctor friends of mine are
constantly telling me about the guns
they have
when i see this too i'm going are
americans that bad of shots that we need
that much
ammunition i mean my god can't we hit
anything very good
a huge backlog of ammunition here's the
other thing can't they make more
i mean you would think this is a golden
opportunity for them to just really
capitalize on this because it's not
going away
um the political climate is completely
driving this it's not like we're under
quarantine and people have more time to
go
hunting right it's because people are
fearful
hell i've never owned a gun pat you know
i've never owned one but i i want to get
one i mean you've never owned it i've
never owned a gun
and you're a conservative yes but i've i
you know i grew up with hunters
everybody in my family hunts i've never
cast a fishing pole
hell i could do more damage with a tool
i could probably hurt somebody just
trying to fix something
you know change a light bulb and i could
kill three people
you've never never shot a gun okay one
time when i was living in omaha and a
friend who was a police officer in omaha
we went to the shooting range and she
let me do it but
i've never had the interest to i've
never felt threatened i've never felt
like i needed a gun
but i'm i'm definitely going to get one
now are you
how do you talk to your kids about guns
how do you talk to you you know what i'm
a little bit worried about i don't like
the thought of having a
because i'm not a gunman yeah you know i
i don't like the thought of a novice
like me
having a gun in the house i would want
to make sure i was doing all the right
things have one of those uh fingerprint
safes
where that's the only way you can get it
that's the way i would do it but you
know what it's not a topic because it's
not something
that i'm into i don't take them hunting
i don't do that kind of stuff we don't
watch
you know violent shows like that so it
really is the only shooting i'm talking
about is teaching dash
you know flawless jump shots and you
know how to get off a screen and that
kind of thing but
i this is this is a very eye-opening
stat here
the fact that we have this much
ammunition that people want to buy that
they can't
steve what do you think well i'm i'm a
country boy so
i grew up hunting um you know
since the earliest age i can remember uh
have a
rather large variety of weapons now in
my house and it's
it's quite honestly i do have a weapon
or two for personal protection in the
house but the rest of it i'm just a
collector
you know i have a couple collectors
items that i'm really proud of i've got
a 20th anniversary dea
45 cal colt 45 1911 that's
never even had the slide pulled back on
it it's in pristine it's still got the
cordite on it and everything
um but i agree exactly with with what he
just said in the fact that
this is being politically motivated you
know
i mean i've got a um i guess now that i
stopped thinking about i do have a
pretty
large array of ammunition in my house
just because i used to shoot competition
but you know what i retired from dea in
2013 so over seven years ago
i've carried a gun twice since then
believe it or not from 2013 until today
only twice
yeah believe it or not so you feel
pretty safe in america today well
where i live it's pretty safe it's you
know it's uh
it's today one of them
[Laughter]
i can't carry it on the plane anymore so
what do you say if you're having a
conversation with a
man that's getting married who has kids
what is your advice
about having gun in the house well i
think
okay so being a country boy i think we
have responsibilities as
the father as the male leader of the
house that doesn't make you the leader
of your wife
but you're the male leader of your house
i think one of our responsibilities is
to teach our children about weapons
now my two sons i taught them how to
hunt uh you know the first thing you
teach them is gun safety i used to be a
firearms instructor for dea first thing
you teach is gun safety second thing you
teach them is how to clean that stupid
gun because that's the thing you hate to
do
that will keep you from shooting so much
because you've got to clean your weapons
or they won't function correctly
but the safety is the biggest thing now
i say that i'm responsible for teaching
my children i've never taken either one
of my daughters out to shoot
but my oldest daughter who she's 27 now
i've seen pictures of her on the range
shooting an ar-15
she's 4 foot 11. the gun is taller than
she is
she's right out there so i'm an advocate
of teaching gun safety because you never
know what you're going to encounter
you know when we were going overseas one
of the things the additional trainings
that dea put you
through is they would send you to
quantico for a couple weeks and
one of the big classes was weapon
familiarization because you never know
what you're going to encounter i've
never seen an ak-47 until i got to
columbia
thankfully i knew how it operated
because it i
need a rose you know so you need i think
you need that training if nothing else
to develop that respect for the firearm
this this junk that's going on about
outlawing firearms
well okay let's take all the guns away
from the legal people from all of us
none of us can have guns anymore you
think the criminals are going to abide
by that
what a stupid thought to have that's one
of the most ridiculous as stupid as that
is why are millions buying it
i have no idea i i just
i think they will as i say i guess i'd
refer this as the herd mentality because
this is what
the people that i associate with myself
with that's what they think so that's
what i'm going to think
i don't want to have an independent
thought i don't want to go out and
experience it for myself and find out
what the truth is
i'm just going to go with other people
what they tell me to do which
that's kind of like what the media would
like to do i think well you know they're
coming after the
guns i mean we don't want to turn this
conversation into it but you would
imagine that is on the checklist of
agenda items of what they want to
accomplish well i mean
in this room just so you know there's
m16s in this room and there's guns in
this room
in this room okay uh in a safe back
there there's plenty of ammunition here
in this room
in the house there's plenty as well i'm
all about it i think
men should have it uh you know the
moment you get to a point when you have
a kid
something you ought to consider having
by the way i fully also understand folks
who are raised in an environment that
maybe they didn't have you were raised
around hunters and you know
you know minnesota right it's a very
normal thing to have but i do think it's
something that you ought to have and
nowadays
you know steve sometimes the most basic
thing like i asked my nanny why didn't
nanny why didn't i like guns she says
because i don't want the kids to have
access to it i said well then you can
buy
safes that kids don't because sometimes
you know country folks sometimes have
guns sitting on their shelf and all of
it like it's comfortable stuff like
that yeah we got one right here i got a
shotgun you know if somebody comes in i
can just pull it out
but i think sometimes it's safety and
nowadays you can literally get one of
these saves it's right next to my bed
you put your finger bone
two seconds gun is out you're good to go
rather than let me go
let me pick it up let me open up the
safe no boom boom
right and then you're the only one that
can get in there yes yeah you can
control it to make
uh uh the fingerprint be you your wife
and whoever else you want and then
nobody else okay you can do it one two
three people
they have that kind of system few
hundred dollars to get one it's not like
you're spending that kind of money
i think steve's considering a new
business selling some of that ammo you
have in your house
i saw a light bulb go off when you
realize how much you have sitting around
in the house there's a market for it you
know honestly i didn't know that was a
problem until i was
i go to a gym most morning monday
through friday
very early and some of the guys in there
are rather conservative and they're big
muscle-bound guys
and i heard them talking one day about
not being able to get ammo and they
ordered it and there's a three-month
backlog and
that's crazy i couldn't believe it i was
shocked to learn that that was just here
probably in the last month or so i mean
what's the point of having a gun if you
can't get ammo i mean that's a major
problem
well so we went some of the articles
that javier and i used back in the
fight against pablo escobar are now on
display at the mob museum in las vegas
and one of the things they have is my
smith and wesson nine millimeter that i
carried
you know back during that time is just
on display in the case and some other
items
and when i went to ship it out there i
had to go to a gun shop where they had a
a federal firearms license so they could
ship it for me legally
and i was shocked at how few weapons
were in the case i'm used to going into
gun stores and there's
lines and lines of rifles and shotguns
and just cases full of handguns
i was shocked at how small the inventory
was in this gun shop
the fact that more americans want to buy
guns right now in october was record
breaking 65
just tells you where we are today and
how people are feeling because a lot of
these people that are buying guns are
probably not traditional gun owners that
they have a collection these are a lot
of people that are saying look i just
want to get a gun to make sure my
family's safe i have no idea how to use
this
but i'm going to go get a gun to see uh
to make sure
my family's protected and that leads me
to the one state that definitely needs
more gun owners california
[Music]